China has made a decision to end Hong Kong's free status.
End of May, 2020, the national people's assembly,
the highest legislative body in the people's Republic of China voted to
implement a new security act in Hong Kong that will give the Chinese regime the
opportunity to pursue those propagating speeches,
ideas and political messages in the currently autonomous city,
a law that will allow the Chinese dictatorship to deploy its security and
intelligence services to Hong Kong,
to put an end to any symptoms of descent in this image that you see on screen ZZ
ping himself is voting in favor of this law.
This image is a reflection of how China is slowly swallowing.
The formerly known Pearl of the yeast.
I can't imagine living under the shadow of the secret police.
It seems that the last firewall that protects our freedoms is about to collapse.
Alan, a Hong Kong university student, and a statement to the Asia. Nick,
how you review the model of one country.
Two systems that had been guaranteed to the people of Hong Kong is being
completely broken down. This is the saddest period in Hong Kong.
I have no words to express in words,
the sense of despair that we have Dennis Kwok CRO democratic member of Hong
Kong's, legislative tremor, Hong Kong,
hedge funds explore the exit as a national security law looms.
The financial times.
Is a topic that we are especially concerned about on visual politic and
something that we have already talked about in a recent video here on the
channel. However, one question remained unanswered.
How has the international community reacted as to what looks like at the
beginning of the end of what has been until now,
one of the freest territories in the world? Well,
the truth is that the international condemnation has been clearly lukewarm
lukewarm because in general, practically, nothing has been said or done
The country that has made the most noise has been the United States,
which has threatened to stop considering Hong Kong as an autonomous territory.
And that could mean that some of the advantages the city has in its relations
with the United States would soon disappear. We're talking about privileges,
such as reduced tariffs, free movement of people with capital,
almost unlimited access to U S technology.
And even the absence of restrictions on exchanges with the.
Big action was taken today by the Trump administration against the communist
Chinese party, secretary of state Palm PEO notifying Congress,
that Hong Kong is no longer autonomous and no longer warrants,
special treatment under us law.
So far, it has limited threats only in the commercial sphere,
which would be of little relevance because direct exports from Hong Kong to the
United States are minimal. However,
the United States is not the only country that is taking action, indeed,
despite the lukewarm international response and beyond the application of
sanctions, that would mostly punish the very people of Hong Kong.
Some measures have been put on the table that are as a genius,
as they are potentially effective friends. Can Hong Kong be saved, listen up.
Metropolis or Hong Kong 2.0.
Let's see if there is one country that has a particular responsibility for what
could happen in Hong Kong. It is the United Kingdom. After all,
almost half of all Hong Kong citizens were born when Hong Kong was still
governed by the British crown.
And that is precisely what has made the government of this country speak out,
of course, in a very different way than the United States.
Look at this headline because here you can see that shots have clearly been
fired.
June 3rd,
2020 Boris Johnson pledges to admit 3 million from Hong Kong to the UK New York
town.
Yes, that's right. The British authorities.
First reaction has been to extend a kind of lifeline for all Hong Kong people
who may feel threatened by the growing control of the Chinese dictatorship.
And as you all know,
Hong Kong was part of the United Kingdom up until the 1st of July, 1997,
the dates on which the transfer of its sovereignty to Chinese hands was
affected.
However.
Despite being part of the United Kingdom until 97 Hong Kong citizens didn't have
British citizenship since back in the 1960s,
but only the rights to reply for what is known as British overseas nationality,
a status that gives any of the approximately 350,000 Hong Kongese that are
eligible for it,
a British passport and the possibility of using the services of embassies and
constellates of the UK throughout the world. It is a status, however,
that does not grant holders, the rights to live.
Work in the UK.
Well,
what Boris Johnson's government is currently proposing would go much further on
the one hand allow the possibility that the nearly 3 million people who were
born in Hong Kong before 1997, may reapply for their status. On the other hand,
to extend the rights this status would entail.
You see the idea that the government has put on the table is that this status as
a British overseas,
national would now allow all holders to stay in the UK for 12 months,
holders can easily apply to be able to work and study in the country.
And the 12 month period can be extended without any difficulty.
And not only that,
the idea circulating in the British government is that this method could also
become a convenient path, a shortcut to for British citizenship.
If China continues on this path and implements this national security
legislation,
we will do so we will allow holders of British overseas nationals passports to
come to the UK and apply to work on study for extended periods of 12 months.
And in turn, provide them with a path to future citizenship. Dominic Rab,
UK foreign minister.
That is the UK is given Hong Kong citizens a whole new escape route.
But hold on a minute,
is London thinking that suddenly hundreds and hundreds of thousands of Hong Kong
residents will pack up and move to the UK?
Well.
Obviously not. However, if this initiative were put into action,
most Hong Kong nationals would have a very attractive path for escaping the
accesses of the Chinese government. That is anyone who is eligible,
could easily escape whenever they see fit without having to go through the
complicated procedure of seeking political asylum. For example,
if as the Chinese government seems to want its control over Hong Kong and the
freedoms of the Hong Kong people are to be made stricter many politicians,
entrepreneurs, dissidence,
and students could at any time move to a safe Haven with all the guarantees that
they would need. And not only that at the same time,
it would push the Chinese government to think twice before crossing a red line,
because doing so could lead to a complete brain drain and talent.
And this is a situation that does have a precedent in the late 1960s and early
1970s,
Ugandan dictator idiom in and the Kenyan government expelled tens of thousands
of people of Southern Indian descent,
who in many cases had a British passport in 1972 and faced with this situation,
the British government of conservative Edward Heath made it possible for
thousands of these refugees to settle in the UK,
nearly 30,000 people followed this path leading to one of the most socially and
economically successful migrant cohorts.
The country friends.
We are facing an ingenious solution that under the circumstances,
could it be the best possible response to China's threat, unlike sanctions,
not only does it not punish the Hong Kong people themselves,
but it actually gives them a whole new lifeline.
And it is a move that has certainly infuriated China.
[Inaudible].
Gee Jinping's government has already made it clear that it is absolutely opposed
to this measure and has threatened retaliation.
And when Beijing talks about retaliation,
you can be sure that they're talking about financial retaliation,
which by the way,
raises serious doubts about whether London will eventually carry out this move.
Let's not forget the weight that China could bring to bear on the post-Brexit
economy. In any case. The question that comes up is,
but what if with the support of the international community,
the British government granted this privilege to all Hong Kong people,
wouldn't that be a master response to GG pings, expansionist veracity,
wouldn't that be a way to make Hong Kong a symbol of the UK commitments to free
countries in the fight against the expansion of authoritarianism?
Well, it doesn't all went here.
Another idea has been put forward a much more original idea that could spell
revolution. Something that I would say probably won't happen, but in any case,
it is interesting to keep in mind.
Could you imagine what would happen if the UK pushed for a creation of a kind of
new Hong Kong in its own territory? Now stay with me.
I haven't quite lost the plot.
It's an idea that the Adam Smith Institute has put forward.
And the truth is that it wouldn't be as far fetched as it might seem at first
glance,
Following the example of the square mile and above all Johnson's proposal for
free ports that we have already talked about on visual politics,
the United Kingdom could enable a space within its territory where any Hong
Kong, citizen, or company, it could be freely transplanted,
a space that would have regulations and the tax system similar to what currently
exists in Hong Kong.
Today.
In other words,
we're talking about creating a special economic zone that become the best
connection point between Asia and Europe, whilst giving Hong Kong citizens,
even more options. And no, it's actually not such a crazy approach.
Keep in mind that much of the UK is economic success over the past few decades
as centered on the square mile and the special regulations that the UK approved
for the financial industry, this would basically be something similar.
In addition,
it would also be a way for the United Kingdom to increase its competitiveness,
strengthen its ties with the Asian continent and attract business and talent
just when it needs it.
Most having carried out Brexit I've old moved don't you think? Well,
that's what.
I'll leave it for now. But the UK.
There is another country that is also following very closely.
All that happens in the former Pearl of the East.
A restless first cousin.
Is keeping a close eye on the events that are taking place in Hong Kong.
And in Taipei, they are clear about one thing.
If she shipping's government gets its way with Hong Kong,
its next move may be to increase pressure on this Island,
an Island that is becoming the last refuge for many dissidents and political
players who refuse to bend to the need of the Chinese dictatorship.
Now that helps explain, for example,
why applications for resident's permits in Taiwan by Hong Kong.
Citizens are skyrocket.
Number of Hong Kong are seeking residency spikes.
The number of people from Hong Kong, applying for residency in Taiwan last year,
Roos 41%, the Taipei Titans.
Of course,
this also carries a risk and in Taipei they have many doubts about which path to
choose. Now let me explain. On the one hand,
they have a great deal of sympathy for Hong Kong residents who have rebelled
against the Chinese attempt to increase control over the city.
But on the other hand,
it's not clear that anchoring the Chinese government too much,
maybe the smartest option.
For the time being.
Article 18 of the Hong Kong and Macau act provides that the time when these
government will provide the necessary assistance to residents of Hong Kong and
Macau whose security and freedom are immediately frightened for political
reasons in practice. However,
this law has not been developed and the process for asylum applications,
deadlines and available budget is unclear so far.
The Taiwanese government has not wanted to open up this panel.
That is precisely why president citing wing,
who as we already discussed in previous videos is not exactly very friendly with
Beijing announced at the end of may,
the formation of a task force to make a final decision and to ensure once and
for all the rights that Hong Kong citizens who apply for asylum in Taiwan will
have one way or another.
And this begs the question should the international community resolutely support
the site when government to make Taiwan the great refuge in the face of
authoritarianism and the growing expansionism of the Jewish in pink regime.
This is one of the questions that international news should take notice of at
this point in time.
Hong Kong is more.
Then justice city.
It is now becoming a symbol of where things could over the next few years.
And we honestly believe that one of the worst things that can happen is that
economic problems will make the Chinese government give full prominence to its
political agenda and the trade war doesn't help there anyway,
that's where things stand.
But what response do you think the international community should give to
China's growing meddling in Hong Kong's local affairs,
leave us your answer in the comments. And if you found this video interesting,
don't forget to hit the like button.
And also this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that
platform. We thank you regards to your wall and we'll see you.
[Inaudible].